روسيا تعلن احباطها هجوما نوكرانيا مضادا
على دانيت فيما التزمت كياف الصمت
ان كل اجراءاتنا الاخيره حتى في شهر ابريل
تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه معنا
هي حوار خاص مع العربيه وزير الطاقه
السعوديه يؤكد ان اتفاق خفض تاج النفط حتى
نهايه 2014 غير مسبوق
في سابقه هي الاولى من نوعها الامر هاري
يبدا معركته ضد الصحافه الصفراء انتقاما
لمقتل والدته الاميره ديانا في افادته
امام القضاء
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه اعلن المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اجور كونان
احباط هجوم واسع النطاق شنته القوات
الاوكرانيه على خمس قطاعات من الجبهه في
اتجاه يونوناسك وقال كشونان ان القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تتكون من ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتاي دبابات حاولت في صباح
الرابع من يونيو اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه
الا انه تم احباطها دون ان تحقق اهدافها
اضاف ان اكثر من 250 جنديا قتلوا خلال هذا
الهجوم
كان الجيش الاوكراني قد جدد مطالبته
بالتزام الصمت فيما يتعلق بتنفيذ هجوم
مضاد طال انتظاره ضد القوات الروسيه
وتزداد تكهنات ازاء ما يتوقع ان يكون
هجوما واسعا للقوات الاوكرانيه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها روسيا في شرق
اوكرانيا وجنوبها كانت السلطات في الاونه
الاخيره حمله على المواطنين الذين ينشرون
صورا او لقطات لمنظومات الدفاع الجوي وهي
تسقط صور خروسيه
روسيا تتصدى لهجوم اوكراني واسع النطاق
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعلن احباط هجوم
اوكراني على خمسه قطاعات من الجبهه في
اتجاه جنوب دونات
القوات الاوكرانيه تكونت من ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتي دبابات
القوات الاوكرانيه كانت تهدف لاختراق
دفاعاتنا في اكثر مناطق الجبهه ضعفا
برايها ولكنها لم تنجح بذلك هذا ما كشفه
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت مقتل 250
جنديا اوكرانيا على الاقل وتدمير سته عشره
دبابه
واحدى وعشرين عربه قطار مصفحه
روسيا اعتبرت ان هذا هو الهجوم المضاد
المنتظر فيما التزمت اوكرانيا الصمت
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيلكرود الروسيه ان
هجوما بطائره مسيره اسقط عبوه الناسف
اشعلت النار في منشاه نطاقه في المدينه
ولم تسفر عن اصابات
في صوره جديده لمعادله فرض القوى بين
روسيا واوكرانيا وجهت سلطات موسكو في
منطقه شبكينو باقليمي بالجورود احد معاقل
الاقتتال الدائر بين الطرفين مناشدات
للسكان للتعاون مع السلطات ومغادره
منازلهم دعوات جديه تظهر حجم القلق الروسي
من اشتداد رقعه القصف الاوكراني على
الحدود منذ اسابيع
احس القرى وخصوصا منطقه شبكيينو التي
تعرضت للقصف على الاستماع لموقف السلطات
والمغادره مؤقتا من منازلهم من اجل الحفاظ
على اهم شيء وهو حياتهم وحياه المقربين
منهم
الاتم من الفوضى على الحدود بحسب مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه التي هددت بالتدخل لحمايه
بولغورود اذ لم تتصدق قوه موسكو هناك
لمحاولتكيف قلب موازين المعادله العسكريه
لصالحها والتقدم خطوه اضافيه امام موسكو
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع في المستقبل
القريب ما يحدث في منطقه بلغرود لان ما
يحصل هناك هو استيلاء على اراضي الاتحاد
الروسي والمنطقه لاجل هذا اشدد على اننا
سنذهب الى بالقرود لحمايه شعبنا الروسي
منطقه شبكيينو باتت جزءا جديدا من خط
المواجهه مع اوكرانيا فهي واحده من
المناطق الواقعه حاليا تحت نيران كييف
كونها تبعد عشره كيلو مترات فقط عن حدودها
ماذا فعل الاف من السكان الى النزوح هربا
من ضربات الموت فهذه هي الفتره الاكثر
دمويه لمناطق اقليم بالقرود منذ بدايه
الحرب بحسب الخبراء
اقترح رئيس الشيشان رمضان قديرو فيرسال
قوته الى منطقه بالقرود الروسيه لمواجهه
من وصفهم بالمخربين ومجموعات الاستطلاع
الاوكرانيه واوضح قدره القضاء على مجموعه
قطاع افقاع الطرق داخل اعراض روسيا من دون
الاضرار بالسكان والبنيه التحتيه يتطلب
معرفه وتدريب او تدريبا مدروسين كذلك
يتطلب الامر خبره في مكافحه الارهاب
تتجاوز الخبره العسكريه
في السياق المتصل اعلنا البيت والابيض انه
لا يمكن التنبؤ بتوقيت بدء محادثات السلام
الروسيه الاوكرانيه على مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جوكس ان الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد سيؤدي الى عوده مناطق ذات اهميه
استراتيجيه اضاف ان تطور الاحداث في ساحه
المعركه سيؤثر بشكل كبير على مستقبل على
مستقبل حوار كياجو موسكو هذا واكد مستشار
الامن القوميين الرئيس الاوكراني قال
بنفسه ان الحرب في اوكرانيا لن تنتهي الا
بالدبلوماسيه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوات اسطول
المحيط الهادئ بدات بتنفيذ مهام تدريبات
عمليه في مياه بحر اليابان وبحر اختاسك
وقالت الوزاره في بياننا المناورات تاتي
وفقا لخطه تدريب هيئه اركان القياده
والسيطره العسكريه لقوات اسطول المحيط
الهادئ في الفتره من الخامس حتى العشرين
من يونيو في مياه البحر اليابان اوضح
البيانون اكثر من 60 سفينه حربيه روسيه
وسفينه دعم ونحو 35 طائره بحريه واكثر من
11 الف جندي من القوات البحريه يشاركون في
التدريبات العسكريه
قال وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه قال انه كانت هناك حاجه لاتخاذ
اجراء اضافي في ظل الظروف الراهنه مشيرا
الى انه حصل توافق على تمديد تخفيضات
الانتاج النفطي الى نهايه 2024
اعتقد انه كل اجراءات من الاخيره حتى في
شهر ابريل تخفيض اللي سوت الدول المشاركه
معنا
لمنفرده سويتك كقرار منفرد لكل دوله هو
قرار تحوطي
واعتقد انه
في ظل الظروف الراهنه كان في حاجه للتخاذ
اجراء اضافي لكن تقديرنا هو انه في كان
بتكون صعوبات على دول لم نتواصل مع احد
لكن لانه حتى الدول القادره على التخفيض
كان لهم تخفيض في ابريل لسه بادي نتائج
المفروض نشوف تقييم النتائجها في في منتصف
يونيو
واضاف وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ان افضل وسيله لمعالجه
الامور والاعتماد على منظور واضح مشيرا
الى ان الجهات مستقله ستعمل مع دول اوبك
بشان تقييم انتاجها في 2024
تعبنا من تعطي دول الحصص ما هي قادره
تنتجها
تعبنا من
ادعاءات انه هذه دوله تقدر كذا وتقدر تنشف
فقلنا افضل وسيله
لمعالجه الامور هذه اللي يسمونها
بالانجليزي
انه عندك منظور او مدى واضح
تتصرف هذا المدى يتعزز عندما تكون الياتك
منضبطه باجراءات تمكن من تعزيز الموثوقيه
فيها
اختتم تحالف اوبك بلاستيج اجتماعات استمرت
ليومين بعد التوصل لاتفاق جديد تضمن مستوى
مستهدفا جديدا للانتاج عند اربعين مليون
و460 الف برميل يوميا بدايه من عشرين
ما يعني تخفيض الانتاج في 20 24 بواقع
مليون و 400 الف برميل يوميا من مستويات
اكتوبر 20 22
بعد ذلك خرجت السعوديه باعلان منفصل حيث
اعلنت عن تمديد الخفض الطوعي الذي اعلنته
سابقا بمقدار 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه 20 24 كما اعلنت عن تخفيض تطوعيا
اضافي لشهر واحد قابلا للتمديد اعتبارا من
اول يوليو بمقدار مليون برميل يوميا ليصبح
انتاج السعوديه تسعه ملايين برميل يوميا
ويكون مجموع خفض المملكه التطوعي مليونا
ونصف المليون برميل يوميا هذا قرار يساعد
على يعني تعزيز فرص استقرار الاسواق ومنعه
من التذبذب الحاد والتذبذب الحاد ياخذ
الناحيتين نشف فقط الى الاسفل ولكن ايضا
الى الاعلى نعتقد ان هذه الاجراءات هي
الاجراءات اللي يجب ان نتصرف اننا ناخذها
كمنتجين مسؤولين عن
مره اخرى نريد ان نثبت العالم انه نحن
نعمل
كبنوك مركزيه فعليه ناضجه تملك الادوات
والوسائل اللي تعزز من انها تمارس هذا
الدور
بفاعليه وبمهنيه
وقادره على انها تحقق هذا الاستقرار
المطلوب ولحق عدد من الدول بقرار السعوديه
تمديد التخفيضات الطوعيه منها الامارات
والعراق والسلطنه عمان وروسيا ليبقى
اجمالي التخفيضات الطوعيه حتى نهايه عشرين
اربعه وعشرين نحو مليون وسبعمائه الف
برميل يوميا تضاف الى تخفيضات رسميه سابقه
بمليوني برميل في اكتوبر الماضي عدد تخفيض
السعودي الاضافي في يوليو
ولمعالجه النقاشات حول خطوط الاساس
للانتاج اتفقت بلس على تقييم القدرات
الانتاجيه لكل الدول الاعضاء بنهايه يونيو
20 24 من ثلاث جهات مستقله ليؤخذ ذلك في
الاعتبار عند تحديد مستويات الانتاج في 20
25 محمد زهير العربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد الفاصل
قياده الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه تعرين
اعتراضها طائره اخترقت المجال الجوي
للعاصمه واشنطن ثم سقطت في غابه بولايه
فرجينيا
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف عضو لجنه البرلمان
اللي بيع عز الدين قوارب كشفل العربيه عن
البرلمان اللي باقرار قوانين اجراء
الانتخابات بعد الاعلان عنها بحضور رئيسي
مجلسين والدوله مضيفا خلال حديثه للعربيه
ايضا عن وصول البرلمان الليبي لتفاهم
النهائي بشان قوانين الانتخابات الليبيه
وان المترشحين للانتخابات الرئاسيه
سيخوضون جولتي تصويت اجباريا هذا وذكر
ايضا عضو اللجنه عن البرلمان ان العسكريين
المترشحين للانتخابات سيكونون مستقلين
حكما عند تقديم اوراق الترشح وانه لن يتم
السماح بترشح من صدر بحقه حكما نهائيا او
جنائيا
غدت ليبيا ساحه صراع بين واشنطن وذكر
تقرير ان سفير روسيا الجديد في ليبيا
يستعد لتولي منصبه في وقت تفكر فيه
الولايات المتحده باعاده فتح سفرتها هناك
يبقى النفط الليبي مصدر الجذب الاساسي
للقوى العالميه
ليبيا ساحه صراع على النفوذ بين واشنطن
وموسكو فبينما تفكر امريكا في اعاده فتح
سفارتها في ليبيا يستعد سفير روسيا الجديد
بالفعل لتولي منصبه الجديد في طرابلس
النفط مصدر الجذب الاساسي للقوى العالميه
حسب بلومبرج فمجموعه فاجنر الروسيه تمتلك
بالفعل امكانيه الوصول الى منشات النفط
الرئيسيه في ليبيا كما ان قرار موسكو
باعاده ترسيخ وجودها الدبلوماسي في طرابلس
غربي البلاد اوضح مؤشر حتى الان على ان
بوتين يتطلع الى تحقيق تقدم يتجاوز دعمه
التقليدي للجيش الليبي
التحركات الروسيه في ليبيا غدت مصدر قلق
كبير لامريكا التي ارسلت عددا من كبار
المسؤولين بينهم رئيس وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه
لمواجهه الدوري الروسي الذي احرزه بوتين
في احد
الذي تتودد اليه الحكومات الاوروبيه كبديل
محتمل للطاقه الروسيه يتصدر جدول الاعمال
الامريكي محاوله للاطاحه بما يقدر بنحو
2000 من قوات فيجنر الذين دعموا حمله حفتر
2019-2020 للاستيلاء على طرابلس وساعدوا
منذ ذلك الحين في تعزيز قبضته على امدادات
النفط في بلد يضم اربعين في المئه من
احتياطيات افريقيا
لكن الولايات المتحده في وضع غير مواطن في
ليبيا حيث لا توجد لديها قوات ولا وجود
دبلوماسيا حتى الان
اما الكرملين فيدرك ان امريكا تريد اضعاف
نفوذ روسيا في ليبيا كما يبدو ان بوتين قد
استقر على سياسه دعم الوضع الراهن وهو وضع
يحتمل ان يترك صدرات النفط الليبيه
رهينه لروسيا التي تشعر بضغوط العقوبات
على مبيعاتها من النفط الخام
قلى وزير الدفاع الامريكي لودوست من الصين
تقوم بتصرفات غير مسؤوله بعد حادث اقتراب
مدمره صينيه من سفينه حربيه امريكيه في
مضيق تايوان اعتبر اوستن انه لما تقوم بها
الصين امر خطير للغايه وفق تعبيره
ما قلته في الاسابيع الماضيه وخاصه في
اليومين الماضيين لقد عبرت عن قلقي بشان
السلوك غير المسؤول الذي رايناه مع عمليات
الاعتراض القريبه وبينما كنا قادمين رايت
مثالا على احدى طائراتنا التي اعترضتها
احدى طائراتهم على مسافه خطيره للغايه وفي
اليوم الاخير فقط راينا حادثه اخرى حيث
عبرت احدى سفنهم امام احدى سفننا ربما
تكون هناك 150 قدما او شيء من هذا القبيل
وهذا امر خطير للغايه
بحر العلاقات بين بيكين وواشنطن لا يهدا
ملف تايوان الابرز في واجهه الصراع ويكشف
الكثير من الخبايا رغم تاريخها البحري
الممتد لطالما اعتبرت الولايات المتحده
الصين قوه بريه بامتياز وضعيفه الى حد
بعيد على مستوى البحر غير ان الوقائع تقول
عكس ذلك المعادله تغيرت فمنذ حوالي عقد من
الزمن بدات الصين مرحله جديده من تطوير
قوتها العسكريه البحريه حيث انتقلت من صفر
حاملات طائرات الى ثلاث واخرى في طور
البناء البحريه الصينيه اقدمت ايضا على
تحديث الكثير من قدرات المراقبه البحريه
لتلائم قدرات الاخرين كما انشات بكين
علاقات جديده مع القوى الاقليميه حيث تفتح
موانئ لسفنها الحربيه لزياره اماكن بعيده
كباب وغينيا الجديده في جنوب المحيط
الهادئ بالقرب من سواحل استراليا الصين
تسعى ايضا لانشاء قاعده بحريه كبيره على
طول الساحل الشرقي لافريقيا حتى تتمكن من
الحصول على موقع دائم على طول ساحل المحيط
الاطلسي
يقول خبراء انه بمجرد ان تتمكن الصين من
تامين سيطرتها على المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ فانها ستطور اسطولها البحريه
لتكون قوه اكبر وبعد ان تعزز قبضتها على
المنطقه يمكنها ان تندفع خارج نطاق نفوذها
وتبدا التدخل في نصف الكره الغربي وهو
مجال نفوذ واشنطن التقليدي بلال البجدين
العربيه
مع اقتراب الانتخابات الامريكيه هل سينجح
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا في ابعاد ترامب على
الانتخابات القادمه اما ان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق سينجح في الفوز والعوده
الى مقعد الرئاسه مجددا الصحف تقول لنادي
سانتوس ليس لديه فرصه امام ملك الميديا
كان يفترض ان يكون منافسا دونالد ترامب
الرئيسيه في السباق الرئاسي المقبل روندي
سانتس اراد ان يشبه ترامب في كل شيء محافظ
سياسيا لكن من دون ارث ثقيل في الحكم كان
يمكن للرجل اللاتيني الاصل ان يسحق ترامب
بالضربه القاضيه لكن شيئا حصل في مسيره
ديسانتس لحظته السياسيه تترنح فها هو
ترامب عائد بقوه تحت الاضواء وربما مجددا
الى طريق البيت الابيض في هذه المبارزه مع
ديسانتس
يبدو ترامب رجلا جديدا في اخر مقابلاته
التلفزيونيه فاختار طريقا لم يعهده من قبل
وهو التركيز على السياسات والافكار بدلا
من الاغتيال الكلامي لخصومه
ترامب الجديد هذا يربك وربما يقصيه بدل
الشتائم المعهوده تحدثت ترامب مع فوكس
نيوز عن الاستقلال في مجال الطاقه عن
التغيير المطلوب في برامج التعليم عن
مواجهه تدفق المهاجرين عن تطبيق القانون
وعن الامل والسلامه في المدن
واكثر من ذلك كله نعت ديسانتس بشكل متكرر
منافسه ترامب بالمحتال قد يكون ديسانتس
تبنى الفكره القائله ان قياده معسكر
الجمهوريين تتطلب قدرا من التنمر والهجوم
السياسي لكن تلك الوصفه القاسيه ورغم انها
نجحت مع ترامب الا انها لا تبدو نافعه مع
ديسانتس
[موسيقى]
وننبه مشاهدينا بهذا العاجل حيث تعلن في
هذه اللحظات السلطات الروسيه اسقاط
مسيرتين على طريق سريع في اقليم كالوج
ايضا سلطه روسيه تعلن السقوط مسيرتين على
طريق سريع في اقليم كالوجا نواصل حيث
اعلنت قياده الدفاع الجوي في امريكا
الشماليه في بيان نشرت على صفحتها الرسميه
على موقع تويتر انها اعترضت طائره مدنيه
من طراسيسنا اخترقت المجال الجوي للعاصمه
واشنطن تابع البيان وانا الطيار لم يستجب
لمحاولات الاتصال حتى لحظه سقوط الطائره
في غابه بولايه فرجينيا وانهم من غير
الواضح ما اذا كانت الطائره دخلت المجال
الجوي المحظور عن قصد او بسبب حاله طارئه
[موسيقى]
شارك نحو نصف مليون بولندي في تظاهرات ضد
الحكومه في شوارع وارسو هي الاكبر منذ 30
عاما وفقا لمنظميها تدفق المحتجون من جميع
انحاء واجابه لدعوه حزب المنصه المدنيه
المعارض للاحتجاج على غلاء المعيشه ودعما
للديمقراطيه والانتخابات الحره والاتحاد
الاوروبي رفع المحتاجون لافتات كتب عليها
يكفي ضد الحزب الحكم
من المتوقع ان يدلي الامير هاري اليوم
بافادته امام المحكمه العليا في بريطانيا
في قضيه ضد مجموعه ميرور للنشر على خلفيه
مزاعم حول استخدام المجموعه لمحققين
واختراقها لهاتفه للحصول على معلومات تم
استخدامها في صناعه الاخبار ليكون بذلك
اول فرد رفيع المستوى بالاسره المالكه
يقدم ادله امام محكمه منذ عام
1891 في وقت تصف به وسائل الاعلام
البريطانيه هذه المحاكمه بقضيه العصر
تعتبر افاده الامير هاري حاسمه في معركته
ضد الصحافه التي يلومها في وفاه والدته
وفي تخريب علاقته بعائلته منذ زواجه بميغن
ماركل عام 2018
تطورا طبي مبشر في مساعي الحد من مرض
السكري وعلاجه بعد ان تمكن علماء من
اختراق الخلايا البشريه التي تنتج
الانسولين وفق دراسه حديثه يامل الباحثون
ان يساعد هذا البحث في دفع الجسم الى
انتاج الانسولين بشكل طبيعي مره اخرى
لمرضى السكري والذي يعتبر واحدا من اسرع
الامراض المزمنه انتشارا على مستوى العالم
وفقا لدراسه اجريت عام 2022
[موسيقى]
وفي نهايه نشره تذكير بابرز العناوين
روسيا تعلن واحباطها هجوما اوكرانيا مضادا
على
اعتقد انه كل اجراءات من الاخير حتى في
شارع ابريل تخفيض اللي سويت الدول
المشاركه معنا
في حوار خاص مع العربيه وزير الطاقه
السعوديه يؤكد ان اتفاق خفض انتاج النفط
حتى نهايه 2004 غير مسبوق
في سابقه هي الاولى من نوعها الامير هاري
يبدا معركته ضد الصحافه الصفراء انتقاما
لمقتل والدته الاميره ديانا في افادته
امام القضاء
حيث نشرع شكرا لكم على كرم المتابعه في
امان الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات